what do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about him he's just super
genuine yeah and it's just really fun to
just
hang out and do nothing and if you ask
kim kardashian's beau pete davidson he's
ready to make things officially official
we'll just have to wait and see a source
is opening up to et about the pair's
relationship explaining kim and pete are
doing great she definitely foresees a
strong healthy and promising future with
him he is so respectful of her and
treats her like an absolute queen he is
completely enamored by her beauty and
talent he thinks she's an awesome mom
and would more than likely take their
relationship to the next level in a
heartbeat why not let's not get ahead of
ourselves though because the source says
kim isn't quite there yet she still has
a lot of unresolved issues with kanye
going on and now isn't the time but
solidifying their relationship further
is a definite possibility down the road
the tension between kanye and kim who
filed for divorce in february 2021 has
unfolded very publicly with pete often
at the center of the drama liking
kanye's bizarre music video for his
track easy god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
another point of contention pete's
tattoo in honor of kim and the four kids
she shares with yay you just gotta roll
with it you know the one on the
comedian's neck that reads
k-n-s-c-p which fans speculate stands
for kim north saint chicago and psalm
our source says pete got the tat as a
way to show kim how much respect he has
for her and her family but when it comes
to yay well the source tells us that
he's still upset about it in fact he
can't stand it but all the while the
rapper is trying to focus on himself and
heal in his own ways i'm just extremely
happy can you tell by my face
tattoo drama aside we've been told pete
is a source of security for kim and that
their relationship is easy seamless and
fun they are completely themselves
around each other and kim feels
incredibly comfortable protected and
secure when she's with pete yeah
and while kim may not be ready to take
their relationship to that next level if
it does happen seems safe to say pete
has earned that kardashian stamp of
approval the family are all totally
obsessed with pete and absolutely adore
the fact that he has so much love for
kim and her little ones they 100
approve what do you all love about pete
i love that he's kind
and really really thoughtful he's the
most thoughtful person
and i love
yeah and i love the chemistry that kim
and him have together it's really sweet
you said the chemistry i was like okay
chemistry
chemistry
that can be a new fragrance
[Music]